[NO SOUND]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
RETO MEIER: Good afternoon,
everyone.
My name is Reto Meier.
I'm a member of the Android
Developer Relations team.
And welcome to the first
ever episode
of Dev.Bytes Backstage.
I'm joined today by Chet
Haase, Dev.Byte author
extraordinaire.
And we are here today to answer
your questions about
animations.
So if you have a question that
you would like to ask Chet,
you can either join us live
via HangOut, which you can
find the link to if you go to
the Google+ event page.
Or you can type your question
directly into the comment
stream on event page
or on YouTube.
While we wait for you guys to
ask us your questions, we have
a few prepared from people
who have asked
before we got started.
And I think we'd like to find
out a little bit more about
Chet as well.
So if you could tell us a little
bit about yourself and
what you're doing on
the Android team.
CHET HAASE: I am an engineer on
the framework team, which
is the team that brings you
things like application life
cycle, the UI tool kits,
graphics, activities, all that
kind of good stuff.
Specifically, I work on graphics
and animation stuff.
So I sort of wear different
hats at different times.
I have done a fair amount
of work on animations.
I also help out with the GPU
acceleration and general UI
graphics goodies.
RETO MEIER: Very nice.
Excellent.
All right.
So let's get started.
Our first question is from
Andrew Hughes from San Luis
Obispo in California.
He asks, let's say you have
a view group that is added
directly to the Window Manager,
such as a pop-up, and
a child view's layout changes
size, causing the entire
pop-up view to change size.
How would you animate the view
groups' size change?
He's watched the Dev.Bytes
on layout transitions.
And he's tried to set that
layout transition using the
transitionlayout.changing on the
view group that's added to
the window manager.
This causes the child view whose
size changed to animate
to the new size.
But the parent view group
just jumps to the new
size without animating.
CHET HAASE: Yeah.
So the way that I think about
layout transition is, it's
really good at doing very
specific things.
And sometimes you fall outside
of the bounds of what those
specific things are.
And you, Andrew, have done so.
The problem is that that view
group does not have a parent
in your situation.
And what you really need to do
is set a layout transition on
the parent of the children, or
of the view hierarchy that you
want to automatically animate.
So if there was a way to have a
parent there, then you would
set the layout transition
on that instead.
If not, it's up to you.
You can use similar techniques
to animate the bounds of the
view group.
Although you're actually
resizing the windows, so
you're probably down to doing
expensive things like actually
changing, I don't know, window
manager layout params to
actually resize the
window, which is
going to become costly.
You may, instead, do something
different, like actually pop
up a window that is of
the correct size.
But you're animating over a
transparent area and faking
out what it looks like
to the user.
There's another technique we
demonstrated at I/O and will
be coming out as a Dev.Byte
soon-- wait a minute.
No, it came out two
weeks ago--
called activity animations,
which is about launching
activities with transparent
backgrounds to fake out the
fact that the activity is there,
but we're going to
animate into it.
Maybe you could do something
like that in this situation to
basically not have it at the
full size when it begins, but
then sort of animate
the sizing more.
I don't know specifically
about your situation.
But I would say that layout
transition is probably not
going to solve that problem for
that top-level view group
that's in the window.
So you're going to need
to figure out
something else that will.
RETO MEIER: Thank you.
Good answer.
So I'm going to rely on Daniel
to let us know when someone in
the Hangout is ready
to ask a question.
So if you are joining us via
Hangout, do be sure to type
into the chat bar within the
Hangout that you are ready for
a question.
Because we often get people who
just want to join Hangouts
because it's more
fun that way.
So you actually have a question
to ask, please do let
Daniel know, and he will
put you up on screen.
In the meantime, Moritz Post
from Germany wants to know,
what would you use to do
Gaussian blur effects within
an application?
Is Renderscript still something
that can be used for
That
CHET HAASE: Yes, in fact.
There was a portion of
Renderscript specifically
around doing actual display
graphics that was deprecated
and that is no longer the way
that Renderscript is going.
However, Renderscript has
another important component
that is having a lot of work
done and has a lot of
important performance-related
advantages, which is the
ability to do image
processing.
So it can use GPU as well as
CPU resources, multicore
processing.
You get all the advantages of
all the compute power that the
device has using Renderscripts
and doing inherently
multi-threaded algorithms
on it.
So, for instance, you could
do a Gaussian blur using
Renderscript using these
primitives in the
non-deprecated part of
Renderscripts to get excellent
performance for doing
things like this.
There are other ways to get
Gaussian blur, but I would say
what you want to do
is end up in the
highest-performance area.
Which means you're basically
going to be using Renderscript
if you want to stay at that
level, or OpenGL as well If
you want to do things a little
bit more manually.
Renderscript might be
a little bit easier.
It might also allow you to
stay within the SDK level
you're more comfortable with.
But I don't know.
It's worth checking out.
It isn't possibly an expensive
computation
to perform at runtime.
So it does seem worth checking
out Renderscript to get the
best performance you can.
RETO MEIER: Very nice.
Everyone loves Gaussian blur
effects over things.
So that's a good question.
Let's have a look.
Emile Schlanda says that you and
Romain mentioned a custom
view with a code-generated drop
shadow in one your talks,
presumably at I/O this year?
CHET HAASE: Yep.
RETO MEIER: So he'd love to know
the best way to achieve
this, both with performance in
mind, and the fact that a drop
shadow will often want to be
drawn outside of the view's
clipping rectangle.
It would be very annoying to
take the drop shadow into
account when doing the layout.
Also, how do you handle
this drop shadow
for non-square views?
CHET HAASE: So there's a couple
of different pieces of
information there.
First of all, you might want to
check out the Dev.Byte that
came out, again, a couple weeks
ago called Activity
Animations.
Because that had a simple layout
in the back of it that
would allow the objects inside
the container to cast their
own shadow.
So in that case, we didn't have
a clipping the problem
because it was the container
itself that was actually
drawing the shadows
behind the views.
So it basically iterate through
the children whenever
it needed to draw itself and
say, where are you now?
I'm going to draw the
shadow there.
And then it also had a couple of
properties that allowed you
to vary what we call the shadow
distance, which created
an offset as well as a blur
around that to simulate the
action of the view being closer
or further from the
actual surface that it was
projecting the shadow onto.
There are different ways
to achieve this effect.
The one that we used in that
particular activity was to
render a rounded rectangle into
a bitmap and blur that
operation in the
bitmap itself.
And then when we drew the
bitmap, it was going to be
naturally blurred.
Especially around the edges,
which is what you care about.
For rounded shapes or
non-rectangular views, we just
drew a flat-out round rectangle,
because that was
the effect that we want.
If you have a specific shape in
mind that you want to use,
I believe the technique that
I heard that you could use
instead is to create
a bitmap that's--
I think it's an alpha
eight bitmap.
And the details are
escaping me.
But you should be able to get a
similar blur effect there to
get the effect that you need
with the shape that you
actually want to draw, instead
of the simple rounded rect
that we were using there.
But go ahead and check out the
Dev.Byte as well as the code
that goes with it.
You can at least see
what we were
doing for the I/O example.
Which is maybe a starting
place for you.
RETO MEIER: Very nice.
Do we have anyone on the Hangout
who would like to ask
a question, Daniel?
DANIEL: Not at the moment.
I'm asking away.
But no one seems
interested yet.
RETO MEIER: By all means,
take this advantage.
I'm going to go through a few
more questions which we've
pre-screened.
Once we're out of questions,
we're going to stop talking.
So if you do have anything that
you'd like to ask Chet
about animations, now is a
fantastic opportunity.
CHET HAASE: We may be forced
to sing a song if
there are no questions.
That's not a threat.
That's a promise.
RETO MEIER: Did we
bring Dan Galpin?
He's my song proxy.
Whenever there's a need to break
out to song or dance, I
get Dan Galpin in the room.
CHET HAASE: Does that
clear the room?
Or is that a good thing?
RETO MEIER: Well, I don't know.
I leave.
So I have no idea what happens
from that point onwards.
In the meantime, Andrew Moore
from Leeds has managed to
avoid us having to break into
a musical number quite yet.
He wants to know how you would
go about creating the
animation effect that's being
used more and more in Google's
own apps, such as the one in
Currents in the List/GridView
to slide in the item at the
bottom of the list elegantly.
CHET HAASE: Yeah.
So this question actually
confused me.
And then I realized that we
hadn't actually played the
Dev.Bytes before the
question was asked.
And now we've done that.
Because we were unable to have
this Q&A period last week.
So I would suggest you go back
and actually watch the
Dev.Bytes that we posted last
Friday, which was called
ListView Anim Removal
Animations?
I can't remember.
RETO MEIER: It was ListView
Deletion Animations, if I
recall correctly.
CHET HAASE: So that one
specifically did a very simple
swipe maneuver.
It was not--
I'll get back to that
in a second.
It wasn't, probably, what you
want to do in real apps.
But it was good enough
for the demo app.
But then after it was wiped
out, it would animate the
items around it to
close the gap.
The nuance there is the swipe
animation used a very simple
heuristic that said, move
it onto your finger.
And then if it's gone past a
certain amount, then simply
animate it away very quickly.
What you actually want to do in
real applications, and what
we do in the Google applications
like Gmail, is to
use Velocity Tracker to figure
out how fast the finger was
moving when they let go.
And if it's moving under a
certain speed, then we'll
actually snap it back based
on that information.
Otherwise, we'll animate it off
the screen based on the
velocity that the finger
was moving at.
That's a little bit
more effective.
It gives the user a little bit
better-connected feeling to
the application.
Because it's behaving in a much
more WYSIWYG manner than
the simple demo that we had.
But you can at least see the
mechanics of actually
animating the item out or back
in and then animating the gap
closed, which was the
real intent of that.
RETO MEIER: So that's
interesting.
So it's actually more intuitive
for people using app
to base it on velocity of finger
movement rather than
the distance which you're
transitioning the object off
the screen.
CHET HAASE: Well, it was
very easy for me
to base it on distance.
I would think it's not
that much harder to
use velocity instead.
Especially since we have
Velocity Tracker as a public
class that you can
get a hold of.
It's going to be a little bit
more work, which is why didn't
bother to do it for the
purposes this demo.
Because that's not where
I was focusing.
But it's not that big a deal.
And more importantly, it's the
user experience that you want
in that sliding application.
RETO MEIER: Very nice.
OK.
Let's have a look.
So I don't know who asked
this question.
But in the new Hangout app, some
people really like the
way that new messages
animate in--
CHET HAASE: Isn't that nice?
RETO MEIER: --from the input
to the chat history.
And even more importantly, how
the previous messages animate
up to make room.
How would you go about creating
a sequence of
animations like that?
CHET HAASE: That is tricky
from a couple
of different angles.
I'll cover them.
I don't have a pat answer
for you because it
depends on the situation.
One of the reasons
is, imagine this.
Imagine that you're typing text
into an edit text with a
certain font size.
And then you want to place
it as just a text view, a
non-editable text view in the
chat window as it scrolls up
the screen.
Well, does that have
the same font size?
And what's the text going to
look like in that view?
And how does that compare
to how the text looks
like in the edit text?
So how do you actually animate
from one view that is
completely different into
another view with the same
text, but may be different
text characteristics?
Or at least different text
measurement, because it's not
exactly like the edit text.
So there's some tricky
nuances thereabouts.
Even if you have the same size
text, you want to make sure
that you're actually going to
animate it from and to the
correct locations in these
completely different view and
layout situations.
So assuming that you can
actually solve that problem,
or that you're actually
animating the same kind of
view, or you can fake it out
well enough, or you can
cross-fade between them, the
other element here is to have
the ability to basically
do a flyover of views.
What you want to do is move a
view from one container to
another, or at least a facsimile
of the view.
One important thing to note in
graphics and animation is,
it's not always necessary to do
the right thing, as long as
you do the thing that
looks good.
So in this case, do
you actually need
to fly a text view?
Or is it good enough to simply
fly a graphical representation
of the text?
And you can actually
do either one.
If you want to fly just a bitmap
of the text, you can
snapshot whatever it
is that you want to
represent the text.
And then you can basically have
a custom container that
draws that on top of everything
else that's
happening at the same time.
You could also take a view,
basically create a view on the
fly, or remove that view that
you had from the parent that
it was in, and then place it
in an overlay container.
And then the animate that.
And the way that works is,
if you picture layers of
containers--
let's say you have a frame
layout and it has a ListView
in it which represents the
chat content so far.
And then at the bottom of
it, it has an edit text.
Well, you could actually take a
view out from the bottom, or
create a new view on the fly,
and place that directly into
the frame layout.
So you could--
let's see.
Yeah.
Right.
You're taking it out of its
container at the bottom.
And then you're putting it into
the overall container
that also contains
the ListView.
And then as that container
draws, it can then draw that
other child there.
So you're adding it as a child,
basically, on the top
layer of some layout
that's at the back.
Maybe your main content
view or whatever.
And then you can do
whatever you want.
You can animate the balance
of that thing.
You can animate the
translation position or whatever.
You can scale it on the fly.
Then you could do crossfade
tricks.
Once it's in that layout that
allows it to lie on top of
everything else that's in there,
you can do whatever you
want with it.
Then place in the
correct place.
The real trick there,
though, is--
as I said at the beginning
of this incredibly long
paragraph--
figuring out a view that's going
to correctly represent
that view from the starting
position and
location and size.
And the same thing at the end.
So that to the user, it actually
looks like the same
object, even though
it probably is
not the same object.
RETO MEIER: Sounds like
a lot of sneakiness.
CHET HAASE: There is a
lot of sneakiness in
animations in general.
Again, as long as it looks
good, it's good enough.
RETO MEIER: Excellent.
That's our slogan, isn't it?
For Dev.Bytes?
As long as it looks good,
it's good enough.
Follow-up question, which you
may have answered in that very
long paragraph.
So let's say you've
got a chat client.
And when the chat loads, you
see the top of the list to
begin with-- so the least
recent messages--
for a moment.
And then it jumps down
to the bottom.
Is there a way to avoid that
when you're displaying that
chat list to begin with?
So if you open up the window
and it's got the list, and
then you want to scroll to the
bottom straight away when the
activity is loaded.
CHET HAASE: Yes.
So if you go back and watch
I/O talk called A Moving
Experience, where we did a
lot of animation demos, a
particular trick-- or, if I
were to be more proper, I
would say "technique" that you
saw in almost every one of the
demos that we showed was using
Pre-draw listeners.
And you can use this when
an activity launches,
basically to let--
when an activity launches, we're
going to do everything
we need to, including layout,
and figuring out where things,
and loading the resources, and
getting everything ready.
And then we're going to draw
the activity, right?
And when we draw that activity,
by definition,
everything will be correctly
positioned the way that it
needs to be.
In your case, the way that it
needs to be might be with
content actually moved up,
animated up or whatever.
And so what you can do is
set a Pre-draw listener.
So that right before we actually
draw the frame, you
can go in and change some values
so that what we draw is
going to be different than
what was automatically
determined by the default
situation.
And maybe there's a better, more
correct way to do this
with layouts to actually
do this correctly.
But there's an underlying
question here, which is, when
is the first time that I can
actually get my hands on the
bits that are going to display
on the screen?
And it's that Pre-draw
Listener.
So you basically get the View
Tree Observer for any view in
the hierarchy.
Add an On Pre-draw Listener.
Put your code in there that's
going to do whatever it is--
start an animation, move stuff
around, do what you
need to do in there.
And then remember to return
true from that so that the
draw actually happens.
It's a little nuance.
If you use an ID and it
auto-generates the boiler
plate code--
I know Eclipse does this,
anyway-- it automatically says
Return False.
So in your Pre-draw listener
you are canceling the draw.
Don't do that.
RETO MEIER: Helpful.
So what do you actually
get back from
the Pre-draw listener?
So, at that point, do you
have access to the
inflated layout view?
Or do you have access
to the canvas?
At what level are
we looking at?
CHET HAASE: You have access
to everything
that's in the view hierarchy.
So before you create your view
tray on Pre-draw listener, if
you've gotten references to
things from the layout that
you set as your content
view, then those
references will be valid.
And you can query the bounds of
those and figure out where
things are and shift
them around.
So a lot of the animations that
we showed that talking
I/O consisted of figuring out
where things needed to be, and
then setting initial values for
those, and then animating
them into place.
If you want to be views
to slide in
or fade in or whatever.
Because at the time when you
get that first callback,
everything has its correct
bounds and position and
orientation.
And you can do whatever you want
with that information.
RETO MEIER: All right.
So it's a way to
preset things.
So if you know what you've got
there is the right place for
them, you can say, actually,
I want it all.
When my activity launches,
I want everything
to slide into place.
So it'll pop or fade
or whatever else.
So you Pre-can it in the
reverse direction.
CHET HAASE: Now, there's a
related question that I don't
really know how to answer.
Which is, well, maybe the
correct thing for you to do is
actually lay things
out differently
and reposition them.
Catching the On Pre-draw and
setting things up for an
animation is a slightly
different, hackier solution,
where you're not actually
setting the correct position
of these things, which would
require actually setting
layout params and doing
a Request Layout.
And we've already done
the first Layout.
So it's a little bit late for
you to then come in and say,
OK, now, at this time, I'd like
to do this other thing.
For that logic, you'd actually
want to do that
a little bit earlier.
Maybe in On Activity Created.
On Created?
On Create?
On On On.
We have a lot of On methods.
RETO MEIER: That's true.
We do.
CHET HAASE: And at that point
you can sort of set up the
layout for what you
need to be.
And that will generate
a Request Layout.
And that'll put things in the
correct Layout position.
And maybe then you don't even
need the On Pre-draw Listener.
But the On Pre-draw is a nice
trick when you actually need
to figure out, let the system
do the real thing, and then
tell me what's going on before
you put it on the screen.
RETO MEIER: That sounds like
it's almost a case of figuring
out what the most common
scenario is.
So if you're going to do it
every time, then hacking into
the On Pre-draw Listener
is probably overkill.
You should probably just do
it in the layout somehow.
Whereas, if it's a one-off or
something unusual, then that
may be a better approach.
CHET HAASE: I would say more
that if you're going to start
hacking things and faking out
layout, that you may end up
causing artifacts.
Like, if you say, no, that's not
where I wanted it to be,
and then you ahead and you set
the left-right-top-bottom
position, regardless of where a
layout wanted to place those
items, then if another layout
happens to run in the next
frame, your positions would get
clobbered by the real layout.
So if you actually want to lay
out these things at the right
place, then figure out the
right layout solution.
As opposed to the more animated
sliding things in situation.
RETO MEIER: Right.
So avoid Gotos in your
layout hacks.
CHET HAASE: Go to is considered
harmful it turns out.
RETO MEIER: Go figure.
You learn something every day.
OK.
So this next question, it's
about as long a paragraph as
your earlier one.
So bear with me while I--
CHET HAASE: Once upon a time--
RETO MEIER: --see if I can
distill this slightly as I
read it through.
So I've got someone who's
working on an app.
So--
sorry, this is Hannes
Dorfmann.
He's working on an app.
Which is a great start.
Really important for us.
And it's going to
animate a box--
so let's say it's a Custom
Action Bar, so a box along the
top of your activity--
in and out while you're
scrolling.
Sort of like the Google Chrome
app does with the URL box.
So as you scroll, it's
going to make this
box appear and disappear.
But the scroll animation
contains some kind of sub
animations.
So his action bar should
change its height on
scrolling, and also do some
additional animations with the
child views, like icons
text views.
So the first question is,
how does he implement a
height-change animation?
Is that a scale animation?
It doesn't seem to be
something like that.
CHET HAASE: Yeah.
Changing the bounds of
views can be tricky.
Because the bounds of objects,
as well as the real positions
of them, are determined
by the layout.
And to get or to set the real
position and dimensions of a
view, you really need
to let layout run.
Because only the layout,
especially the nested layout
in which that view lives, is
going to be able to determine
the real information
about that view.
So I would say, in an ideal
world, if you want to set the
size of an object or animate
the size of an object, what
you do is change the layout
params, and then let the
layout system figure it out.
In the real world in which we
live, we have constrained
devices that might just fall
over if you force them to do
layout on every frame in a
really complex view hierarchy.
RETO MEIER: And in fact,
that is his follow-up.
Is he was like, I know
how to do this.
I'm going to change the
layout params height.
But--
CHET HAASE: Oh, this was
the follow-on thing?
RETO MEIER: This is the
follow-on, yes.
And it turns out that this has
some performance implications.
CHET HAASE: It does have
performance implications.
RETO MEIER: In fact,
I know this.
Even back in the days where
we didn't have such
resource-constrained
devices, I used to
write code for Windows.
Big powerful machines.
Almost as big CPU power as
these phones do now.
And I had this really
smooth progress bar.
It was a progress, but
it was indeterminate.
And I have a passionate hatred
for progress bars which go to
the end and then start again
from the beginning.
So I built my own.
And it pulsed.
It went in and out.
And it changed colors
and everything.
Because you could do that
in the .NET campus.
And so it's changed the layout
of this object which was
changing colors.
Turns out it's--
CHET HAASE:
[MAKES CLUNKY MACHINE NOISES]
RETO MEIER: Well, no,
it was beautiful.
Because I just took over
the UI thread for that.
Because you want to make
it nice and smooth.
It turns out it decreased the
performance of the underlying
activity by a factor of 10.
CHET HAASE: Animations
are that important.
RETO MEIER: Well, for me,
that was good enough.
Because if it looks good,
it's good enough.
CHET HAASE: That's right.
RETO MEIER: So yes.
That was his follow-up.
So do you have any general
ideas, feedback there?
CHET HAASE: Yeah.
Again, most of my answers
are, well, it
depends on your situation.
In this particular case, there's
a couple of things
that could work.
You've already determined that
maybe scale is not the answer.
And in general, it's not.
Scale is really nice for a
transient effect where you're
popping something out of the
screen, or you're animating it
in, or you're just
giving a little
bounce effect or whatever.
But as soon as you start scaling
things, especially if
they contain text, they tend
to look really awful.
So it's really better as a
temporary effect than to
actually change the size
with the scale.
Especially if you're going to
make this thing taller, so
you're going to scale in y.
Well, that's just going to
stretch out everything
vertically.
It's going to really
look horrible.
That's a graphics term.
Horrible.
So what you really want to do
is change the real bounds of
the object.
But then you have this problem
to solve where, well, if you
animate the layout params,
that's really expensive.
It's the correct solution, but
it's really expensive.
What I have done in some
situations, including the
layout transition class we
talked about earlier, is, you
can actually animate the
bounds of an object.
And you can do that by
call-in setters.
Or you can set up an object
animator to basically animate
left-right-top-bottom, just
as you can animate the
translation properties, or the
scale, or the rotation, or
anything like that.
And you can combine that with
the ability to use the On
Pre-draw listener, which we
talked about earlier, to
basically run layouts, set the
layout params to what you want
them to be.
And that will cause
a Request Layout.
And on the next drawing frame,
we will run layout before
drawing occurs.
So if you add a View Tree
Observer On Pre-draw listener,
then you're going to get a call
after that next layout
has run, but before we've
displayed it on the screen.
And at that point, you can
start an animation--
this is exactly how Layout
Transition works.
You can start an animation
that animates the
left-right-top-bottom bounds.
And you can do so
in a way that is
changing the correct thing.
It's not changing the scale.
But instead it's actually
changing the size of the view.
Now, there's a couple of very
important nuances to this.
One is that the position of
items inside of that view, or
inside of that layout whose
bounds you're changing might
be in the wrong place.
Because you just
layout to run.
Which means they may be set by
that layout to then pop to
their end state.
You may need to do something
with those, such as animating
their relative position inside
the layout at the same time.
You can also do things like
fade text out, resize the
thing, fade text in.
That can be compelling
or effective.
Another problem that you're
going to run into is that if a
real layout runs in the middle
of your animation, then you're
going to have a bad day.
Because the real layout
positions are the ones that
you told it you wanted at the
end of the animation.
So if you said, OK, I want this
thing to be this big.
We're going to Call
Request Layout.
Layout's going to run.
You're going to have your
pre-draw listener.
And you're going to say, OK,
now animate it from this
smaller size up to
this larger size.
If you're in the middle of
that animation and a real
layout runs, it will snap very
momentarily over one frame to
that real end size.
And then your animation
will continue running.
So you're going to see this
flicker artifact as it hops
over the real values and then
continues with the animated
values that you have.
The work-around for this--
again, which Layout Transition
uses, and which you can use in
your own application--
is to have a custom layout and
make sure to stub out layout
calls, or On Layout calls,
during the middle of an
animation, just so this artifact
doesn't happen.
It's a bit of a hack.
But it's really basically
a work-around for the
performance situation
where you know what
you're supposed to do.
But you don't have the
performance to do that across
all devices in all situations.
RETO MEIER: Nice.
CHET HAASE: How's that for
another very long paragraph?
RETO MEIER: That was
pretty good.
I mean, it was a long
paragraph question.
So you have to match it.
CHET HAASE: That's right.
Yeah.
Word for word.
RETO MEIER: That's part of
your contract, right?
However many words are in the
contract, there needs to at
least be that many
in the answer.
We've got a few more questions
from the G+ stream.
People are shy.
They don't want to join
us on the Hangout.
Fair enough.
By all means, keep sending
your questions in.
CHET HAASE: I wouldn't either.
RETO MEIER: He hates
being on camera.
It's awkward.
CHET HAASE: So shy.
RETO MEIER: Hannes Dorfmann
asks, he's wondering how the
Google Play music app
have implemented the
ParallaxScrollView.
Is that a translate
y animation?
I mean, he can use the On Scroll
listener to detect
scrolling in, and then simply
set the translate y of the
view to do step-by-step
animation?
Is that the right way?
CHET HAASE: Is it OK if I
say I haven't a clue?
I don't even know the effect
he's talking about.
RETO MEIER: The parallax
scrolling
in Google Play music.
Just trying to think
what that would be.
I'm not sure myself.
You can say you don't
have a clue.
CHET HAASE: I don't
Sorry.
Without picturing it, I can't
even give you a pointer to it.
So no, I'll have to go back.
RETO MEIER: We should get
someone to show you.
I think our producer Daniel may
have a phone which he can
show us on.
We'll see how we go.
DANIEL: Yeah.
I'm going to check
[INAUDIBLE] now.
RETO MEIER: All right.
Awesome.
In the meantime, we'll have a
look at a question from R
Palan, who says, how do you
consistently animate sprites
on devices with vastly different
processing power?
I know that back in my day,
there was a button on the
front of the computer
that said Turbo.
So you could slow it down.
CHET HAASE: Press the
turbo button.
RETO MEIER: I know
we have that on
any of the new devices.
CHET HAASE: No.
We started removing buttons
from the devices.
I wonder if we got rid
of the turbo button.
RETO MEIER: We must have done.
Because I don't see
it switching
between 8 and 12 gigahertz.
CHET HAASE: Maybe it's
inside the back.
You could take the
back cover off.
RETO MEIER: Unfold one
of the processors.
CHET HAASE: So one thing that
we're really good at doing,
especially when we went to
hardware acceleration, where
moving bits around on the screen
is much faster, is
copying bitmaps around.
If they're really bitmaps, and
especially if they're blended
on the screen and you're doing
a lot overdraw, then things
tend to get expensive.
But if you're just simply
copying small sprites around,
unless you have thousands of
them to copy on every single
frame, you're going to get
pretty good performance.
And this is at the SDK level.
You're just doing a Draw Bitmap
from here to there.
If you're not scaling on the
fly-- actually, scaling on the
fly is even cheap on the GPU.
If the bitmap is not really
huge, if you're not applying
filters to it, which cause extra
processing power and may
reduce some of the hardware
acceleration effects that we
can get, you're going
to get pretty
good performance anyway.
I have seen performance suffer
when someone had a bunch of
small sprites they
were animating.
And by a bunch, I mean 3,000.
When you get up to that level,
and you're iterating through
this tiny little loop to copy
a lot of stuff around, well,
the overhead of sending all
those commands down can bog
down eventually.
But if it's just copying sprites
around on the screen,
GPU is pretty good about that.
There's also tools to help
figure out whether that's
really your bottleneck
or whether there's
something else going on.
So you should certainly look
into using Trace View, which
is an excellent profiling
tool.
A note about it, though, that
it does tend to skew or
distort the timings of things
that are actually happening at
the SDK versus the
native level.
The overhead of the tool itself
tends to make the
numbers seem larger for simple
things like Method calls.
But it can at least give you a
relative impression of what's
going on for performance.
Another one is to look at the
GPU Performance, which you can
enable in the developer
options.
And that will spit out
some numbers when you
do a dumpsys gfxinfo.
And you can put those into a
spreadsheet and see where your
framerate's going
at what times.
And see what exactly
is contributing to
this framerate problems.
And you can also use the
Overdraw tool, which will use
colors on the screen to show
you what's being overdrawn.
Which means, yeah, maybe
copying that
sprite was really cheap.
But you were also copying
a window background.
And then on top of that you're
copying an opaque background
for the application.
And then you've got list
items overlaying that.
And by the time you actually got
to drawing the sprite, it
was the fifth or sixth
level deep.
And we simply ran out of
bandwidth in the GPU to draw
that many pixels
on the screen.
RETO MEIER: Great.
OK.
So here is the Parallax view
he's referring to.
You'll see that the album art
at the top is scrolling at a
different speed to the
list underneath it.
CHET HAASE: OK.
RETO MEIER: So I guess
the question
is, is this an animation?
Or is this just a simple case of
we're tracking the movement
of this particular list
and modifying
the position of each.
CHET HAASE: I believe so.
That's not an animation.
They're just saying, OK, how far
did the finger move, and
how far do we want to
scroll this list?
Because you can scroll a list
either directly with a finger
or programmatically.
I would assume that they're just
doing it programmatically
based on a scaled-down delta
value for the scroll position.
RETO MEIER: That makes sense.
It is a nice effect, though.
Turns out not everything
that looks nice
has to be an animation.
CHET HAASE: What?
RETO MEIER: It's news to me.
I think we've got our last
question here from Maxim
[INAUDIBLE].
Unless we have any more coming
up the next few minutes.
An we've, in fact, gone over our
half-hour allotment, so--
CHET HAASE: No songs today.
RETO MEIER: There will
be no singing.
Good news for everyone.
I get the impression
Maxim may have been
talking to you before.
Because he says he would like
to pick at Chet's mind once
again on view group
animations.
He'd like to know if you could
speak more about techniques
that could be used to expand
view group height-revealing
child elements.
He's put that in quotes.
Feels like either he's asked
you that before, or you've
done a Dev.Byte on it.
CHET HAASE: Or did he ask the
earlier one about view group
animations?
RETO MEIER: Oh.
That's quite possible.
Let's have a look.
I don't recognize the name.
I do try and hideously mangle
everyone's name.
If so, it was uncredited.
But in any case, can you speak
more about the techniques that
could be used to, quote,
expand view group
height-revealing
child elements?
CHET HAASE: Expand your
consciousness.
Maybe I'll add a little bit to
what I was saying before about
actually animating
the real bounds.
You can imagine a situation
where you wanted to expand a
view group to include another
view that was down here.
You could force the
layout to occur at
the On Pre-draw Listener--
I'm getting really tired
of saying that.
We need smaller method
names in Android.
That's really what we need so
that we can talk about them
more quickly.
RETO MEIER: That's what the
learning from today's episode
really is, is smaller
method names.
CHET HAASE: I mean, nothing
beats, there's one class name,
Color Matrix Color Filter.
I think if I can just work in
"color" one more time, then
the world will explode.
OK.
So you have a view group
that's this big.
It has a bunch of
views in there.
And then maybe you get another
one that you want to add there
when the view group
gets larger.
You could set the
layout params.
You could add that
view down there.
Or this will expose the
view, or whatever is
happening in the app.
And then animate the
real bounds.
And then, as I said before, once
you run layout and that
view actually is down
there, that
will be its real position.
And that's where the layout
wants to draw it.
So as you animate the bounds,
then it will simply expose the
thing that's already sitting
there waiting.
I don't know.
That's probably too simplistic
for your situation.
But I don't really know how to
answer it other than that.
RETO MEIER: Without
more detail.
No, I think that's
a good answer.
All right.
Brilliant.
That looks like the last
of our questions.
We're just over 30 minutes.
So that's kind of perfect
for today's episode.
Thank you very much, Chet, for
joining us in our first
Dev.Bytes Backstage.
What do you think of the
name, by the way?
CHET HAASE: Dev.Bytes.
Fantastic.
RETO MEIER: Yeah?
Working for you?
I like Chet.Bytes.
Because you seem to be the
only one doing them.
Nonetheless, we're going to try
and bring in some other
people for a similar Dev.Bytes
Backstage, even if they
haven't done a great
number of Dev.Bytes
for us to talk about.
In fact, tomorrow, Roman and
Nick from Android Design In
Action will be doing a Dev.Bytes
Backstage talking
about some design elements.
And in particular, practical UI
implementation for Android
based on the Google I/O
talk from this year.
So please--
CHET HAASE: If you have other
Backstages based on teams that
actually aren't doing Dev.Bytes,
you can call them
Null.Bytes.
RETO MEIER: Null.Bytes.
Oh, I like that.
I like that a lot.
So stay tuned for more Dev.Bytes
Backstage, and
Null.Bytes, and Null.Bytes
Backstage.
In the meantime, do send us
through your questions for
Nick and Roman for tomorrow's
episode.
And do join us.
Particularly if you're not
feeling shy and like to join
us via Hangout.
You can ask them in person.
They're a lot less scary and
intimidating than Chet.
So hopefully we'll get a few
people to join us that way.
In the meantime, thank you
very much for joining us.
And we'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]